- [Mark] All right, Charlotte.
- Hello.
- [Mark] Charlotte, Where
are you from originally?
- [Charlotte] Utah.
- [Mark] Utah?
- [Charlotte] Yes.
- [Mark] Born in Utah, right?
- [Charlotte] The land of Mormons, yes.
The stereotype holds up (laughs).
- [Mark] Were you raised Mormon?
- Kinda in and out, not
really strictly Mormon.
So I had the choice of
kind of going to church
if I wanted to,
unlike a lot of my friends who kind of
were not given a choice,
it was,
"You're under my house, my
roof, you need to go to church."
So I luckily didn't have
parents that enforced that rule.
- [Mark] Wow.
And how was your childhood
in this really...
- Yeah, I had a fairly normal childhood.
I grew up in Utah, rode horses,
played softball, went
snowboarding, skiing a lot.
Yeah, nothing too out of the ordinary
for a girl growing up in rural Utah.
- [Mark] And do you think,
so, are you a video sex girl
or what is the term for it?
- Cam model.
- [Mark] Cam model?
- Yes, and content creator.
- [Mark] Wow, I see.
Okay, so being a cam model,
do you think that career choice
was a reaction to your religious...?
- I think maybe I had a
little bit to do with,
growing up in a culture
where sex is very, very suppressed
and like taboo and dirty.
And I kinda made me more
interested in it and made me more--
(Mark mumbles)
- Yeah, exactly.
It's seen as very like dirty,
thing you don't ever talk about.
It's like between a man and a woman,
a husband and a wife and that's it.
It's just filthy and all, the context.
And so I guess I've always
kind of been intrigued
by like the taboo
or the,
things that were outside of societal norms
and it kind of just started as a way
to make a little extra money
and it was a little...
It was fun cause it was something that,
I'd like read about and whatnot
but then it became something
that I actually really enjoyed
and wasn't really about the money anymore.
- [Mark] Right.
And now you live in Las Vegas?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And really what you're doing
you can do it anywhere
in the world, right?
You can be in Utah, you can be in Alaska.
You can be in NY.
- Yeah, that's what I love about it.
You make your own schedule.
I mean, it does have pretty rigid hours.
Like you really need to put the work in,
if you want to be a successful
full-time cam model,
video creator,
you have to really put the hours in.
It doesn't like, you can't
just do it here and there.
- [Mark] When you're in the mood.
- Yeah, you have to make a schedule
and you have to stick to it
or else you're not gonna
be very successful.
- [Mark] And how many
years have you been doing?
- Just one.
- [Mark] Oh, just one?
- A little over one.
- [Mark] And what are the
upsides and downsides of that?
- The upsides are definitely
making your own schedule.
I'm able to work from
a safety, my own home.
I'm able to just like
interact with people online.
I'm a bit of an introvert anyway.
So that works out for me nicely
that I can just interact
with people online
and if anyone's rude or anything
I can just block them, just kick them out.
Not have to deal with them
anymore, which is lovely.
- [Mark] No diseases?
- Yeah, no diseases.
Although, everybody
should get tested anyway.
But it's...
Yeah, I like a lot of aspects of it.
The only thing I don't
like, is like I said before,
you have to put a lot of hours into it.
To be a successful cam model
you probably need a cam
at the very least like six
hours a day, six days a week
if you want to be super successful
you should do like
eight to 12 hours a day.
Like it's really a grind
if you want to be like
very successful.
So.
- [Mark] And do you do this
all by yourself or (mumbles)?
- Yeah, I just do it on my laptop.
Just set it up with a webcam.
And when I live cam that's what I do
and then I also make custom
videos for my customers.
So that's another thing that I do.
Same thing, just set up
my camera and my phone
and film what they like.
A lot of a girlfriend experiences.
- [Mark] So your personal life,
does this affect like relationships
you have with boyfriends
and stuff like that?
- It has in the past.
It's either people are
really turned off by it.
Find it really like,
whorey, slutty, threatening.
Yeah, whatever you want to call it.
And on the other hand,
people be a little over
fetishizing of it like,
"Oh my God, it's so hot
that you're a cam girl.
"You're probably just love sex
"and want to fuck all the time."
Those were like the two extremes.
But luckily I have found partners
that are normal about it,
let me do my thing,
and we'll keep it separate
from the relationship.
So yeah, there's definitely...
It has in the past caused
a little bit hiccups,
but if someone has an issue with it,
I just kind of drop 'em.
I'm not gonna try to
convince somebody to like,
change their mind.
It's like, "Why? What's the point?"
So, but on the other hand,
if someone that's a
little over fetishizing
of what I'm doing,
then I also kind of just drop 'em
'cause it just kind of icky.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And is there something,
or do you think you're
like very, very sexual,
or do you just like
pushing people's buttons
or what is it that maybe
attracted you to this?
- I definitely have a very high
sex drive and it was also...
I slowly learned it was a good way
to learn my own like sexuality
and like my own turn-ons, turn-offs
and other people's fetishes.
Like I have learned so much
about other people's fetishes
and what they're into.
It's insane.
So yeah, I get to learn a lot about people
and learn about a lot about myself
and also get to try kinky, weird things,
that I probably wouldn't even
have thought of on my own.
So that's another thing
I really like about it.
- [Mark] Right.
And do you get repeat customers
that keep coming back?
- [Charlotte] So that's mostly what it is.
That's why you want to
be on there all the time
because you'll get those people
who want to keep coming back
and keep seeing you and
build a connection with you.
And then you don't mostly...
I mean, mostly being a cam girl
is like 10% sexuality, sex stuff
and the rest is just like
talking about music, books,
- [Mark] Oh, really?
- [Charlotte] My day.
Yeah, I mean, these people
that come to my room
they really just want to know...
Like they just want to get to know you,
'cause if they'd just want to go jerk off
they'd go watch porn
and jerk off and get off and whatever.
But when they come to a cam model,
they're looking for a
little bit more intimacy,
a little bit more connection.
And so, yeah, it's very little,
little what I do is sex on camming.
- [Mark] (mumbles) It's interesting.
- [Charlotte] Yeah, it's a
lot of like human connection.
- [Mark] What's the
strangest request you've had?
- [Charlotte] Oh, someone wanted
me to send them my garbage
like tie my garbage, throw it in the mail.
And I was like, "What do
you think is in there?
"It's like nothing sexy.
"It's like dog hair from my vacuum.
"Like, what are you..."
I don't know what he
thought would be in there.
I don't know what he thought.
I don't know what he wanted or
what he was looking for that.
That's the only one I was like,
I thought was super strange.
- [Mark] Do you have
plans for your future?
Where would you like to go from here?
- I would like to try porn.
I love caming, but it
can be quite isolating
just sitting in your room
alone on the computer
for hours a day, weeks on end.
So I really am interested in
working with other people,
getting into porn.
I've done a lot of
research on the industry
and I think it would be an
incredibly interesting industry
to get involved in.
So I'm definitely looking forward to that.
Trying that out.
- [Mark] Good luck with that.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And, Charlotte thank
you so much for talking to me.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] It was amazing, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.